hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation in the
last episode we spoke about the impact
of motion on the passage of time and
remember it all came from the constant
nature of the speed of light if speed
according to Einstein has strange
properties at high speeds namely near
the speed of light then since speed is
nothing but space / time then we learned
that space and time have weird
properties and we worked out the weird
properties of time in the last episode
today as the counterpart to time
dilation what we did previously we're
going to talk about the weirdness of
space which yields the equation as we
will see that is called length
contraction or Lorentz contraction
Lorentz after a famous physicist who
actually strange enough even though
we're focusing on Einstein here he
actually came up with this equation
first he didn't completely interpret it
correctly and that's really why these
ideas are deeply associated with
Einstein but other people were thinking
about these ideas as well ok so let's
get into it and I'm going to describe
length contraction by using a concrete
example first but before I show you that
little animation let me just give you
the basic idea and then we'll try to
derive it first intuitively through
animation and then I'll write down some
equations that will capture this
rigorously mathematically ok what's the
basic idea the basic idea is if I am
watching an object race by me and the
canonical example that we will use is a
train if I watch a train race by me and
say you are on that train you will
measure the length of the train say and
get a particular value if I then measure
the length of the train that's rushing
by me I will get a smaller value a
shorter length only in the direction of
motion lengths are contracted along the
direction of motion according to an
observer in this case me watching that
object in
motion that's the basic idea and how are
we going to understand this where does
it come from let's get into a concrete
example in fact I'm going to use that
example of the Train let me bring up
some animations I think that will help
make it clear so imagine that the train
is rushing by me but let's focus upon
you first imagine that you are on the
train that is you generic you right
there and how would you go about
measuring the length of the Train will
you pull out you know a tape measure and
you simply go from one end of the train
all the way to the other end of the
train and you'd read off in this
particular case these numbers are
completely made up it's 210 meters
according to your tape measure how would
I go about measuring the length of the
train as it rushes by me well I can't
really use a tape measure at least not
in any conventional way because the
trains rushing by me so as I bring the
the tape measure up to the Train it's
gonna rush away and I won't be able to
do the usual approach to measuring the
length of an object with it with a ruler
with a measuring tape instead there's
something clever that I can do which is
this if I have a stopwatch and if I know
the speed the velocity of the train
along the track here's what I can do as
the train approaches me right when the
front of the train passes me I turn on
the stopwatch okay I let the watch go
until the caboose the very end of the
train goes by me and then I click I stop
the watch so I get the elapsed time from
my perspective that it took to train to
rush by me and then I simply use
distance is velocity times time I know
the velocity of the train I know the
amount of time that elapsed between the
front of the train passing me and the
rear of the train passing me I simply
multiply those two together to get the
length of the train that I would measure
show that in a little a little visual
here so there is there's me and there is
where I'm going to stand and when the
front of the train passes me I start the
watch I let it tick along and then
finally when the back of the train
passes click I stop the watch in this
case
say 5.9 seconds if the speed of the
train was 30 meters per second I would
simply multiply those two numbers
together and the claim is that when I
carry out that arithmetic I will get a
smaller number for the length of the
Train then you got using the tape
measure approach again these numbers
completely made up this is not the
amount of contraction at a slow speed of
30 meters perspective 30 meters per
second I should say so it's really just
illustrative of the qualitative effect
that the length of an object in motion
will be shrunken okay so that's the
basic idea now how do we argue for it
and there are many ways that we can go
about this but the simplest is to make
use of what we already derived time
dilation and simply by using our earlier
understanding of time dilation we can
get this result that I will measure a
shorter length of the train so let's do
that again I've got my handy iPad here
to do that and this should come up on
your screen of the-- yeah the technology
seems to be working so what did we learn
about time dilation well we've learned
that when someone is looking at a clock
in motion from their perspective they
will say that that clock is ticking off
time slowly compared to their clock now
I'm going to do something a little bit
strange right now I'm going to take your
perspective on the train and consider
delta T according to you versus the
delta T the amount of time that you will
claim elapses on my watch the reason why
I'm doing this perspective I'm looking
at things from your perspective first is
a little bit subtle let's do the
calculation and then I'll indicate why I
had to do it this way for this
particular derivation but delta T right
the amount of time that will elapse on
your watch compared to delta T on my
watch we know the answer to that you
will
that more time elapses and you know the
factor by which it is going to be
greater it's one over the square root of
one minus V squared over C squared from
last time in other words the amount of
time that elapses on my stopwatch
compared to the amount of time that
would elapse on your watch measuring the
same events would be given by square
root of 1 minus V squared over C squared
times delta T u so less time on my clock
compared to your clock why is that
relevant well if I consider the length
of your train according to me that's my
measurement of the length of your train
what am i doing well as we described in
that little animation I'm taking the
velocity of the Train times the amount
of time that goes by on my stopwatch but
now using the relationship between time
according to u time according to me I
can write this as V times square root of
1 minus V squared over C squared times
delta T u and then we know that if we
write this as say just move this guy
over 1 minus V squared over C squared V
delta T u this combination over here is
just the length according to u right and
therefore length according to me is
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared times length according to u and
so there you have it right because this
factor over here let me actually give it
a little color to distinguish it this
guy over here is a number that will
always be less than 1 because it's the
reciprocal of gamma in fact I can write
this if I would like as equal to L u
divided by gamma gamma is always bigger
than 1 now that I've
upside-down there and therefore the
lengths according to me will be less
than the length according to you who
measures the length of the train while
being on the train itself being
stationary with respect to the Train so
that's the little derivation that the
length of the Train according to me will
be less than the length of the Train
according to you why don't I have to
sort of play this funny game of of going
to your perspective watching my clock
you might wonder it well you know
couldn't the person on the platform
namely me say that the clock on the
train is running slow and that wouldn't
that give us the reverse result if you
think about it if we try to play this
same game by using clocks on the train
as opposed to a clock on the platform
we'd have to make use of to such clocks
because as your train is rushing by me
you could start your watch as you pass
me but you wouldn't then pass me again
to stop the watch instead you'd need
someone situated at the back of the
train to click off when that person
passes by me there's an asymmetry there
so you need to have two clocks in the
train and that yields a subtlety that we
will come back to in one of the
subsequent discussions and that's why I
didn't do it that way so this slightly
circuitous approach where I go from your
view of my clock to my view of your
length is actually the shortest way to
get to the result that we just derived
now again as with all things in special
relativity the effects are small in
everyday life because the factor of V
over C is usually incredibly tiny and
therefore this gamma is often very very
close to one it is very close to one at
small speeds but a large speeds it can
make a really big difference so let me
just show you an example imagine that
you have a taxicab that is streaking
down Fifth Avenue in Manhattan at a
speed very near the speed of light and
your Y
this very fast-moving taxicab what would
that look like well let me just show you
a little animation of it of course we're
imagining that the speed is close to the
speed of light that's a little hard in
everyday life but where you can do it in
animation and look at that taxicab isn't
that strange right the taxicab is is
shrunken in the direction of motion only
the height of the taxicab is unchanged
it's that it's length has been squeezed
down by this factor of gamma now you
note something else if you look at that
picture a little bit more carefully it's
not only that the taxicab is squeezed
along the direction of motion it's also
twisted a bit right we're seeing the the
back bumper at a kind of funny angle
relative to what you might expect and
the reason for that is that we are in a
situation with relativity where there's
a difference between what's actually
happening out there in the world and
what we perceive when we consider the
rays of light bouncing off of an object
and if you consider the rays of light
bouncing off of the taxicab you're
actually seeing the taxicab at different
moments in time different points on it
because the light from different
locations on the taxicab have to travel
different distances to your eyeball and
therefore you're not seeing the taxicab
the whole thing at one instant of time
you're seeing different points on the
taxicab at different moments in time
depending on how far away those points
on the taxicab are from your eyeball
when you take that complexity into
account you get that interesting
twisting effect that you're seeing in
the animation but the bottom line of
what's actually happening to the taxicab
from our perspective is what we derive
mathematically its length in the
direction of motion is being shrunken by
a factor of gamma now imagine that you
were inside of that taxicab how would
things look from your perspective well
from your perspective the taxicab is not
moving relative to you in fact as we've
emphasized if you're moving at a fixed
speed
direction you can claim to be at rest
and it's everything else that's rushing
by you in the opposite direction so from
your perspective it's life as normal
inside of the taxicab and if you look
out the window it'll be the outside
world that has all this weird stuff
happening with lanes being contract and
again based upon the light travel time
interesting twisting and curving from
your perspective so let me show you that
alternative perspective here it is so
there you are inside the taxicab
everything appears normal
inside but look at what things look like
on the outside
things are shrunken they're kind of
twisted because of the weirdness of the
rate at which different clocks are
ticking and the different distances that
the light has to travel all fold it into
this length contraction in the direction
of motion so that's the bottom line of
how motion effects space shrunken in the
direction of motion the other
perpendicular directions are not
influenced at all and as we've seen we
actually were able to derive it from our
understanding of how clocks are in
relative motion will tick with respect
to one and other okay so that's today's
daily equation keep in mind that the
length me being equal to length of u
divided by gamma you have to interpret
what these symbols mean it's the length
according to me of your length as
measured with respect to a stationary
object you are on the train itself but
if you keep the symbols in your mind
straight we now understand the
relationship between time for you time
for me length for you length for me I
think next time we're gonna take up I
think I'm going to look at maybe
relativistic mass or the relativistic
velocity combination formula see as I go
forward again love to hear more of your
suggestions which I'm keeping a list of
and as we go forward I'll try to
incorporate your suggestions into the
equations that we discuss
okay but that's it for today that is
your daily equation look forward to
seeing you at the next episode take care